it appears to have been an organized and
well-executed attack
the president's compound pockmarked with
bullets while security forces
tried to control the scene but it was
already too late
president juvenal moesi is dead his wife
injured
and this chaotic country is now in an
even greater mess
the acting prime minister was one tasked
with breaking the news to the nation
we may leave my information according to
the information we have
a group of english and spanish-speaking
people who were carrying huge caliber
weapons
killed the president as the incumbent
chief of government
and in strict accordance with the
constitution i presided over an
extraordinary council of ministers
where we have declared a state of
emergency across the whole country
a fortnight ago the president was
talking to his supporters
but he has been running low on
popularity for a while now
gangs corruption kidnapping violence and
discontent
have become the byword for life in haiti
we were in the capital porto prince a
short time ago
where people were calling for an
uprising against the presidency
[Music]
the protests have often been violent and
deadly
their ferocity changes from day to day
but they're
always dangerous haiti
has no idea where things are going to go
now
the streets are deadly quiet but nobody
is thinking
that will last long one of the poorest
countries in the world with a history of
violence
is apparently going down a well-trodden
route
of more violence and more disruption
life is always hard here and it's not
about to get
any better stuart ramsey sky news